[Music]
hello my friends welcome to
congratulations
[Music]
all right we are here god sometimes i
just hear my
fr franken
uh
voice in the microphone and it just
sounds like soda you know what i mean it
just sounds like soda filling up a nice
glass
in on a warm summer day
god damn
and it's the end of summer we're
finishing up summer so
um
so just you know what i mean feel my
voice feel my voice
and a nice tall beautiful glass with
some ice cubes some square ice cubes
just clinking around
i love ice cubes that are perfectly
square and that's it i don't want to
talk about it i just wanted to mention
it and i wanted to move on because
that's what i do on this podcast dude
when i dwell on some [ __ ] you're gonna
know it all right you're gonna know it
because it's gonna go on for 15 minutes
but when i want to just touch and go
when i want to roll off a topic like
barry sanders to a defender when i just
want to roll off it into the touchdown
area
i want to just say look
here's the deal i like perfectly square
ice cubes and that's a touchdown okay so
that's it we'll leave that one alone
we'll put it to bed now i've already
been talking about it for a minute does
that mean it's been dragging on for too
long secretly yes but does that mean
that it wasn't by design no it was by
design so oops in your face right okay
now
the deal is
this episode
is
uh
it's it you know it already feels like
it's i feel like i'm in the middle here
i feel like i'm in uh you know do does
he go rip roaring or does he just
[ __ ] kind of chill and do a relaxed
vibe thing and i think i'm gonna meet in
the middle dude i'm gonna shake hands
with the middle of this man i'm gonna
six out of ten and i don't mean
six out of ten on the goodness i mean
six out of ten in the energy uh vibe
because two episodes ago i was going
[ __ ] yeesh crazy dude
i was on uh i was on [ __ ] mach 11 and
people in the comments let me know they
were like whoa crystal lee's going mach
11 and i was like yeah well
but um
so that's what's up uh if you want and
if you love the the the podcast you
could sign up for the patreon
patreon.com christalia now you get a
bunch of extra [ __ ] there's an extra
episode uh and a month and there's also
extended
uh episodes of each episode that comes
out on youtube and another thing called
review mode which is a segment that i do
only for patreon and behind the scenes
and all this [ __ ] we do polls we have
fun we have a discord we chat we do
watch alongs and it's all good so what i
really wanted to get to is
what's going on who this is something
i've thought about for a long time and
i've never really brought it to fruition
on this podcast i've never really
decided to really talk about it because
it kind of was a thing in like the late
uh 20 you know 2000's it was like
this this kind of thing
uh hit the world and then podcasting
started and then this kind of thing got
kind of taken um
it wasn't really dwelled on when the
internet got really popping right
like when vine came out on the scene
your boy exploded when the internet got
involved your boy exploded i was dot-com
you understand i came out and it was
just like okay i'll use this internet to
the to my advantage
and i would say this to other
communities you gotta get on the
internet and they'd be like nah nah nah
it ain't about that [ __ ] nah nah nah i
like to do stand up okay cool how they
gonna come see you if you're not getting
on comedy central if you're not getting
on [ __ ] whatever it is how they're
gonna come see you
your boy grassrootsed it
vine instagram you know what i mean
these youtube kids everyone was laughing
at him and now boom what the [ __ ] on
fire
but what i'm trying to get at is
who and what
happened to make soulja boy
you know what i'm talking about now me
even talking about this is passe it's
like [ __ ]
me being like what's the deal with razor
scooters
or like hey
how's george hamilton get work
that [ __ ] is
it's already passed but it's worth
digging up
and i'll tell you why it's worth digging
up because i keep seeing soulja boy on
the internet
but what's he doing dude
is he rapping
no
he's signing artists so he's got a label
where is it
he made a video game console
what happened to it
and he's got a clothing line i think
probably who wears it
but the guy
has a following like jesus christ
so what happened that soldier boy popped
off and
continues to pop off right it's like the
game you know the game was a hot rapper
he wasn't out there just going you
superman that oh he was a hot rapper
that dude had really real good rhymes
and more than that he had an attitude
right
when you listened to songs by the game
you really felt
the lifestyle and even as a white
boy
i was like i kind of identify with that
in a weird way he got me dude hook line
and sinker
he scooped me up
but soldier boy
what do you do i'm going to google him
actually right now and this is no hate
but he's always like on an instagram
live joining someone else's being like
nah [ __ ] y'all and then it's like it'll
make like [ __ ] rap.com and it's like
saljib i talk [ __ ] to [ __ ] lil penis
or whatever the [ __ ] everyone's rap
whatever the new guy is you know if i
just if i write soulja boy news here we
go 23 hours ago last article hosta run
massage boy
soldier boy tells kanye west to
apologize to taylor swift in twitter
rant
i mean what the [ __ ] dude
let's see what happened here here's
another one from a day ago soulja boy
and chris brown furious that kind of way
cut them from donda
i just dude these guys who make their
name off of or who keep their name off
of talking [ __ ] about the relevant dudes
and i don't mean in a funny way dude
because then i'd be burying myself
i'm making jokes right now on i'm not
even talking [ __ ] about the dudes who
are worth taking shots at i'm talking
[ __ ] about the dudes who are doing that
that's what this podcast is all about
dude i'm taking shots at the dudes who
are taking shots
but soulja boy dude if you straight up
looked me in my eyes and said you know
how old soulja boy is and i said no and
then you said he's 46. i wouldn't i
[ __ ] wouldn't blink i'd be like yeah
well okay that makes sense
soldier boy tells kanye west to
apologize to taylor swift twitter and is
this about
way back when this is about 2009 is
there a more 2009 thing to be
doing then [ __ ] to have soulja boy
tweeting about
how kanye west should apologize to
taylor swift didn't he already apologize
first of all second of all she's past
that
she's the biggest star in the world he's
the biggest star in the world and your
soulja boy
your last hit was kiss me through the
phone
and that was in 2009
or whatever the [ __ ]
soldier boy and chris brown furious by
the way we we we talked about the uh
the the donda album on review mode if
you sign up for my patreon patreon.com
that's the last time i mentioned in my
patreon i did it too long i didn't mean
to but i'm just saying if you wanted to
hear my thoughts on donda that's where
it is
soulja boy and chris brown this is on
newsweek very very very goddamn
reputable source if you ask me
soulja boy and chris brown have both
said they were cut from kanye's new
album donda the highly anticipated much
delayed recording finally uh
collaborative jay-z travis scott and
controversially marilyn manson uh rapper
soldier boy named real name deandra
cortes
labeled
west as a coward for cutting his verse
on the track remote control coward dude
coward
dude
you're not gonna put me on your song no
coward okay that's a cover move wow so
insecure dude ah scentsy
[ __ ] david brent david brent let's
count a bit in there
right you don't put me on the thing it's
coward a bit
because i speak real cause i speak wrong
cause i'm wrong right
dude it's all [ __ ]
it's so ridiculous
i just want to know because soulja boy
did the video games
soldier boy soldier do you remember that
soulja boy came out with a video
game here we go
he released a brand new held handheld in
2021 soulja boy
wow what is soldier boys game console
it's called uh according to
dodo
trdr pocket currently being hawked
by soulja boy is actually based on the
retro pocket which in turn was cloned by
pow kitty i mean so many made up names
okay cool done with it
that's hilarious to release a handheld
video game and be sold your boy how much
is soulja boy worth i gotta know this
soulja boy
boy
uh net worth and you know what i got
this is always all wrong by the way
oh soldier buzz net worth how much does
he make a year seven million come on
dude this year he earned seven million
in 2016 that was 2016 dude who gives a
[ __ ] bro this is always so wrong you
know what and if i'm going to pretend
like there's a radio show and if you're
just joining in we're talking about
soulja boy call in the number 1 800
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um
drake is coming out or came out
depending on when you listen to this
with a new album and the [ __ ] artwork
is rid i like the artwork dude there's
like 40 pregnant
chicks on it
but it's the emojis
that guy has such a [ __ ]
way
of tapping into the mainstream and
tapping into what's like who the [ __ ]
thinking about
using emojis on your album cover is so
not cool but then when he's just like
[ __ ] it i used a pregnant ladies
you're just like damn that's actually
kind of the [ __ ] that the world wants
right now you understand
he [ __ ] lets you know this is what
the world wants right now it's not
really so much soulja boy tell him
anymore it's a little bit more like
drake tell him
but they want a pregnant girls 40 times
they want a pregnant girl emojis 40
times on my [ __ ] album cover
and then he did the nike thing it's the
nike thing now but he put out nike [ __ ]
with flowers on it the dude gets
really cute with it dude he gets really
really cute with it man and that's what
i admire about drake dude did you see
what happened when kanye leaked his
address and then
then drake put the [ __ ] on uh instagram
and he was just smiling all cute with it
like someone else was taking the video
he was in this [ __ ] ferrari or lambo
probably just smiling doing a selfie
acting like someone else was taken in on
the hood of the car while he was driving
with her arm hooked over the windshield
but this is drake just like t heating it
up
he was taking it up and [ __ ]
in the 2.0
like someone else was holding the
[ __ ] [ __ ] on a selfie stick on the
front of the grill of the [ __ ] rari
oh come on drake but drake got cute with
it man
and he was like if you think that's cute
just wait to the certified lover boy
uh album art comes out and it's 19
pregnant ladies and an emoji dude
he's getting real cute with it dude you
can't knock a [ __ ] that gets too
cute with it you can't dude
drake smiles cute
you ever see drake smile
even in a still picture you hear him
going
he's real cute with it dude
everyone throw one shoulder up
forget it dude
one time there was a pizza delivery man
when i was like i was probably 16 i was
still in high school and my mom and i
ordered pizza it was really cute my dad
was on business and my brother was at
her at his friend's house and we ordered
pizza from pizza and the guy came and he
was like in his 40s and he made some
kind of joke and then he went
and [ __ ] afterwards my i did that to
my mom and she left every time dude and
i still do it to my mom to this day and
i was 16 dude that was like 24 years ago
and we [ __ ] if i called my mom right
now and my mom remember that time the
pizza guy went
she laughed dude and that's a mother-son
connection
the pizza hut delivery guy got cute with
it drake gets cute with it those are
memorable [ __ ] dude
if you want to make an impact you got to
get cute with it if you're a man get
cute with it dude
i'm serious
dudes out there saying well you know if
i wear pink you know it's cool because
i'm you know i'm very i'm actually
really in touch with my mac salinity so
it doesn't oh shut up bro you don't know
how to get cute with it give me all that
pink and let me put it on and t hey it
in the big apple
i'll start around new york with that
pink jumpsuit on get killed with it
we talk about be more memorable but get
killed with it
that's how you do that that's a step up
dude you don't have to do that but you
can do that
anyway dude i didn't mean to go on this
[ __ ] rant about getting cute with it
and drake and [ __ ] but the album cover
bangs dude okay
it bangs i don't know if maybe if it's
going to come out you know we're talking
about this before it came out so maybe
he'll change it like kanye did remember
when kanye had that dope album that
looked like [ __ ] it was from a pink
floyd concert
he was gonna release it he put that out
there we'll show a graphic of it right
here but we he put that out there and
then he just released the black square
you know what i mean
like maybe it was like a black lives
matter thing i don't think it was
because it's so after that but
yeah
that's the album artwork just darkness
so yeah soldier boy tell him needs to
get killed with it soldier boy tell him
these people man
and me too i'm in it you know it's not
just them i often talk about hey it's at
somebody it's them but you know
we're all the problem in our own way
dude i'm not people say oh he's [ __ ]
yeah he's always making fun of everybody
else and first of all that's comedy
open the door to it okay but second of
all it's like dude i am doing that
because it's funny but also there's
problems with me too okay i'm not trying
to act like i'm better than anyone
you know i'm talking about when i was in
high school i thought it was cool to
[ __ ] style my hair like jason priesty
i was in uh new jersey and then my dad's
like we got to move to la and i was like
cool let's do it and i started doing my
hair like luke perry and walking around
everyone was [ __ ] making fun of me
and laughing
but guess what i did i still did my hair
like that i walked every day to school
and when i got in everybody laughed at
me but guess what guess who was more
luke perry than luke perry dude
your boy in my head and that's all that
matters
i was [ __ ] luke perry 90210
in lchs high school
and i made sure everybody knew it
i made sure everybody knew ah stupid
hair i go nah it's cool man
and then your boy got real popular with
that confidence he went from the outcast
with the hair to the cool dude with the
hair of course the hair got lower and i
styled it a little bit differently as i
got cooler because i get affected too
i could affect it too
but people are always like you know they
talk about you know life can hit you
fast life can come at you fast you know
we all had weird years last year oh we
[ __ ] woke up and life hit you fast
life hit me fast when i got to la
life hit me fast when i got to la and i
thought i knew how it was going to be i
was one of the cool kids in sixth grade
moved here seventh grade i was
immediately a dork and life hit me fast
but it's not really that you know
life hits you fast but it's more like
you're on your track
and life doesn't
happen
life doesn't
happen to you right people say hey life
happens it hits you fast life happens
but it's not that it happens to you
you gotta let life
hop in dude you gotta be on your track
and then
life
hop on in
right
if life is hitting you fast
if life is happening because it does it
happens but bro be on that track
come on life happen
and t he along the way
throw one shoulder up
one shoulder up for the homies man car
full of homies no chicks t he in it dude
life hops in homie move over we're more
crowded
you understand me it's a mentality
that's why when i talk about life rips
i'm i really mean that [ __ ] life really
rips
this [ __ ] isn't just a saying it's a
culture
this [ __ ] isn't just a saying
it's a cult that's what i'm telling you
man
so let
life hop in and rip with it dude yes
dude
don't let life hit you [ __ ] life dude
is what it is
i'm a [ __ ] i'm a motivational speaker
from now on yeah that's it dude period
i'm a motivational speaker from now on
you understand my baby that's it
i'm a motivational speaker because
here's the deal dude
somebody needs to do it somebody needs
to [ __ ] do it
you know i watch this [ __ ] into the
storm q thing
this queue into the storm
uh his cue into the storm on hbo max
and it's just like it was one of those
things that i just didn't want to watch
because i knew it was going to be heavy
but kristen put it on and i was like nah
come on babe and she was like what just
give it like five minutes and i was like
i'm already [ __ ] if you give something
like this five minutes i'm all in you
think i can i can't you think i could
turn off a documentary about queuing on
bro one time when that documentary loose
change came out i was on the the floor
of my apartment
and i just clicked on it
and i'd watched the whole thing on the
floor of my apartment and i was like god
damn you can't get dude when it comes to
conspiracy theories or breaking them
down or negating them bro i am all in
i'm sucked in dude i'm sucked in forget
it
so i watched this queue into the storm
it's like six episodes i finished it all
in [ __ ] three hours
even though they're an hour each i
finished it very quickly though
it was about how 8chan was created for
free speech because
you know there was a [ __ ] thing that
the gamergate was the first thing that
like stood up to quote-unquote cancel
culture
because
video games were heavily male popul
populated and the characters were male
and they were four men
and then
a vocal minority was like what about the
women characters and [ __ ] like that and
then gamergate
was like
[ __ ] that we want to be
we want our games they can't [ __ ] with
our you know gamers they don't [ __ ]
around dude
if you're near a gamer and you're like
you bring up like red dead redemption
you know it just looks like because
rockstar was severely underpaying their
and you're just like yo bro i just i was
i wanted to be a cowboy and kill a
[ __ ] bunch of people i don't know
what you're talking about dude
it stinks and laugh you know because
it's like
um
yeah so gamergate was like the thing i
think it was on 4chan but it was like
this thing that was like [ __ ] this don't
let the women take over video games it
was highly extremely sexist and you know
it was shitty and then they
i think something like they went to like
limit
the posts about it
so it seemed to be like they were saying
it was like censorship or something like
that so then they made
8chan and 8-chan was his thing was like
[ __ ] it dude this is free speech and
we're going to [ __ ] die by this sword
die on this sword of free speech free
speech and um
they made 8-chan and 8-chan was just
like all of a sudden heavily racist it
was like oh good nazis were like finally
we can just we can chat about it man we
could just talk about these jews
nazis were just like oh there's 8chan
cool rally up the troops come on come
over to 8-chan we're going to talk about
jews
and people from 8-chan would be like
well you could say whatever you want
it's free speech that's what america
that's the cornerstone of what america
was [ __ ] found on
and it incited violence and then that's
how q anon blew up and then people were
like you know q anon was
was the number one thing on 8chan and
that how q anon was like becoming this
huge thing and then it was too late it
was a movement it was reddit banned q
and on post but it was too late because
they were already mobilizing on 8chan
and the people on 8chan the creator of
8chan
um was like [ __ ] it i need to i need to
quit and then so these guys bought it
from them and then they were these free
speech
uh
these people who really believed in free
speech and then the the creator of hn
was trying to [ __ ]
take 8chan down because they were like
oh this isn't right
anyway it's fantastic this documentary
it's like three it's like six episodes
long and the reason why you know that
it's good is because my dad said it was
boring
but um
it was just crazy to hear about these q
anon [ __ ] man
like just insane
like they just leached on to the [ __ ]
save the children thing where it's like
everyone's like hey what's up with uh
like q anon would be like well don't you
believe do you believe in queuing on and
you'd be like nah all that stuff sounds
crazy and they'd be like well what about
the save the children thing you believe
children should be saved right and then
people are like i mean yeah yeah
who wouldn't okay cool then you're with
us and then some idiots would just be
like okay let's do it
[ __ ] it
it's just like dude who it's like hey
they shouldn't
hey you hate crystallized comedy yeah
well what do dude do you like when they
just [ __ ] blow up buildings for no
reason no well chris salia believes that
you shouldn't blow up buildings for no
reason right so he's funny right i don't
know man i i guess so here's a there's a
free ticket well i just i said here's a
[ __ ] free ticket come
okay
followers man
you know and it's just uh
it's just odd because
people are so susceptible to [ __ ]
i mean they think that babies are being
eaten by hollywood elite
i was in hollywood
you know
i've been to the parties
zero babies were being eaten
they don't even [ __ ] eat
carbs do you know what i'm talking about
they don't even eat carbs they're
[ __ ] vegan
it's just
but i came out to this thing with other
i don't even know if i believe free
speech in free speech anymore
i mean i i think it's important i think
free speech i think there should be free
speech
but like hate speech is [ __ ] insane
and i also here's another thing that i
think would [ __ ] absolutely fix it no
anonymous [ __ ] ever again
you have an account online you post you
sign everybody knows that that's you
no doxing doxxing is [ __ ] shitty as
[ __ ] because that's free speech too
doxing you can go out there and be like
yo this is tom cruise's address
free speech
but it's [ __ ] up it's absolutely
[ __ ] up so that free speech am i for
doxing not enough for that i think if
you sign in i think everybody who goes
online has to speak as themselves
if i sign in to wherever twitter hn a
[ __ ] now is what it is [ __ ] um
instagram it's it's crystalia no dummy
accounts right
if you're looking at my story i know you
saw it
there's no dummy there's no finster
there's no [ __ ] you know how much
that would curb violence you know how
much that would curb violence
so much
people be like well i hate jews but i
don't want everybody to know about it
what about that plan nope
whatever i'm just a [ __ ] comedian
i'm just like this boxing shit's gotta
go
i gotta start doxing people man just
straight up people just who people who
disagree with me just be a [ __ ]
on my instagram story so here's somebody
who said something about me and here's
where they live go babies
and they just show up and they just
start going it's like they just started
going
outside of their house
[Laughter]
oh you got daxed
i'll docks people but crazy cool [ __ ]
though man grab a bunch of [ __ ] uh
fruit just throw it on their lawn
doesn't really affect them
but they know what's up
ah so i had to go to the bathroom thank
you guys for still sticking around we
put a cut in there um
we were on a we were on the youtube i
was on youtube and one fire said that
there was somebody getting mad because
they said oh yeah patreon is supposed to
be uncut and it was like there's still
cuts in it it's like dude that doesn't
mean
we're gonna leave in the [ __ ] moments
that lag are the moments i have to go
take a piss anyway um
the uh
this is something i actually can't even
believe that is a real thing this
[ __ ] uh
first of all dude on tick tock it's
called the getting arrested challenge
okay listen here all right not
everything's a [ __ ] challenge
okay
let's just call this i don't even like
that it's a trend but let's call it that
that's what it is all right
or it's just a thing that people are
doing
but this getting arrested challenge dude
where they just i don't know how
i get how one person has this stupid
idea but i don't get how everyone then
starts doing it i know that there is a
big portion of the people doing it as a
joke and making fun of the people who
actually do it but they're making fun of
people who actually do it there are
people who actually do it
and i'm great spill the cook spill the
lacroix yes dude got something here
gonna gonna gonna go look at that dude
look at that
that just wipes it right up it just
wipes it right up spilled the lacroix
and it just wipes it right up and then
you just put it down and it is drier
than the sahara look at that would you
look at that
um
but this
tick tock getting arrested challenge how
about the getting arrested challenge is
going up and punching a cop in the face
that's a challenge
and then running away can you get away
or do you get arrested in this get
arrested challenge
but dude they stay this is a tick tock
where these guys pretend to struggle up
against the wall while they're getting
handcuffed and looking at their
significant other and being like don't
worry about it babe giving them a wink
or some [ __ ] and they put like colorful
lights in the background like sirens are
blaring dude you're in your bedroom
that's wrong
this is by deaf noodles oh wait was this
even by them or what no this is just the
person who posted it
the tick tock is
[ __ ]
here
one fire sent me the original version
tick tock it's
tommy talk jesus that sounds like
somebody who'd do it here we go
[Music]
hands on your back boys and then they
turn and then they're struggling still
oh i mean
oh and he says i love you oh it says i
love you to his significant other and
he's got a letterman jacket on and
that's it no shirt underneath it and
it's falling off his shoulders while
he's getting arrested
and there's another kid also next to him
getting arrested the way less
good-looking one dude how hilarious is
that that the [ __ ] good-looking one
is in the forefront and the less
good-looking one is in the back that's
like his little brother that was like i
do it too
let me do the getting arrested challenge
with you tommy tommy talk
pov the brothers in crime turned
themselves in
oh
dude
what is going on
nope nope can't play it gotta stop it
gotta stop it gotta stop it
dude that's hilarious
are there more that's the num that's the
oh here's another one
here's another one
eyes oh wow oh they turned them around
they pushed him up against him around
him oh ace ventura he's ventura how he
did it
oh growling and blowing out of a
wink-dadder
him probably uh who are we kidding dude
here's the deal man he go dude he goes
like this and he turns around and he
goes and turns like this ace ventura um
dude on the catwalk getting arrested but
still modeling dude
hey
i get it now
strictly for gay guys
you know
it's strictly for gay guys
we figured it out we crack the code
it's strictly forgotten
dude how it's how the rihanna song is
chopped and screwed
up
wow dude
the internet is you know what it is is
there's too many people and so this
stuff's gonna exist because the internet
is there so we all get to watch it
thanks guys everyone's talking about how
cringe it is look at the article here on
sportskita.com
they're just like just as one tick tock
trend ends another begins the newest
growing challenge on the platform
getting arrested challenge showcases
content creators yadda yadda
somebody writes i need but this is what
the things are beyond disgusting and
insensitive tic tocs bizarre new getting
arrested challenge slammed online what's
disgusting and insensitive about it like
that's the thing they're going to turn
this into a race thing watch
here the thing and then they add tweets
here i need you i need the getting
arrested tick-tock trend to be explained
to me do you all think it's hot it's
nauseating to me personally okay fine
that's fine dude that's fine just want
to know why all these caucasians on tick
knock are fetishized and get arrested
there we go already erase things second
tweet in let's guess it's a white person
yup
white person white people have problems
with that
uh white people have problems with white
people
white people eat their own
it's so crazy dude white people are just
[ __ ] what are the animals that eat
their children
there's animals out there that end up
eating their offspring that's what white
people do not all white people by the
way some white people are down ass
[ __ ] but white that's the
[ __ ] the thing that happened with the
jeopardy thing it's white people going
after mike richards they [ __ ] and
nobody's standing up for him dude
here we go they
just cringe
the pov
is all cringe everyone say
who are these people sexualizing getting
arrested on tick tock
whatever
why not make it a racial thing [ __ ] it
why not
it's racist i lose it's racist
it's a hate crime to do that
there's so many challenges dude
even kristen we were filming a video for
youtube
this fall decor video to to put it up on
our house it's up on my youtube and uh
and she and she was like put these
pillows on the couch like how you think
they are
i said oh really i'm gonna [ __ ] it up
she's like no but it's a challenge and
she gave me five pillows i'm like dude
it's not
this isn't a challenge you know
like just this is putting pillows down
god
this sleepwalking woman
long overdue to talk about this
best of selena spooky boo viral
sleepwalking tick tick-tock videos
compilation
oh she goes outside
bro
people who go outside
sleepwalking
are
awake
okay
i don't believe you
you
you you may be in
your your brain may be broken but you're
awake okay
it was also it was snowing out okay
you woke up is if you didn't wake up
beforehand
definitely woke up when your feet
he hit the ice
i mean my brother sleepwalked once and
he walked out to he walked out of the
room
and pissed down the laundry chute he
thought it was the toilet and that's
i can buy that
i sleep walked into my parents room once
when i was a kid and i went and then i
was like dad come on dad come in my room
i don't feel good and he came in my room
and i got into bed and i said hey dad
when is the fire not a fire and he said
uh i don't know when it's out and then i
said uh yeah yeah yeah i went back to
sleep that's it i had a fever though i
had a fever that day
so that's the sleepwalking i can get
behind but the people who [ __ ]
like wake up and drive to saint louis
you're awake you just took a road trip
even if you go to the fridge and start
eating
just because you don't remember what
happens i mean you're sleepwalking also
why does this woman have cameras all
around her house that's weird as [ __ ]
dude
it seems so set up but she's laughing at
it
wow sleepwalking and carrying things
going outside again
[Music]
oh another person's walking
by there we go
oh wow
walks around
getting salt
i just think this is amazing dude matter
maybe it is real i'm no doctor i mean
kristin talks in her sleep sometimes
the other night we were watching that q
anon thing and she and and we were and
she fell asleep before me and she goes
like this she says
she says well she says uh i guess this
just never ends and i was like what
what and she said i guess it just never
ends
i said what and she said q anon
bro
talking in your sleep is so [ __ ] she
talks in her sleep so much it's
hilarious
one time one of my exes was talking in
her sleep and she was like we gotta get
the birthday cake we gotta get the
birthday cake and i was like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about and sure
enough a week later was my birthday and
she threw me a surprise party i was like
oh you ruined in your sleep and i had no
idea dude
she was nice
sleepwalking dude
you know you know in the movies how they
do it like this like zombies
my brother pissed down the laundry shoe
one time when i was a [ __ ] kid i had
that onesies you ever zip up your penis
in the onesies dude one time i zipped up
my balls in the onesies and forget it
dude i felt like i was good i felt
almost like i fainted
i was like
weak in my knees bleeding out of my
balls screaming and i was like well i'm
wearing i was like i zipped up my balls
just [ __ ]
blood spurting out of my balls
wow dude
it's hard figuring it out
calvin had a booboo the other day and he
just keeps pointing to it saying
oh it's so cute dude i love that
[ __ ] i went to go put him in a
bed last uh two nights ago last night
and i went to go put him in the crib and
he was like no da
that and he was like grabbing my shirt
and i was like okay let's go [ __ ] sit
in the chair a little bit longer i sit
on the chair and i'd be like it's okay
it's all right buddy just chill and then
he would just [ __ ] pop up look at me
and say
and i'd say i'm still here and he would
put his head back on my shoulder and i'd
be like don't worry about it buddy and
then i went to go put him back in the
crib again he was like no that that that
that he just stiffed up i'm like okay
let's go back to the chair and then he
would just [ __ ]
oh crying for no reason and then look
back up and he was like dad and he would
look up at me face will be right here
and he'd just be like that that dude and
it was so cute man
he [ __ ] we do this thing kristen
started it but she'll try and like
kiss
he'll like hurt his foot or hurt his
shoulder or hurt his face or something
and then he'll walk over to her and
she'll go like i'll make it all better
and she goes and she kisses wherever the
booboo is and she'll say it's all better
and he'll stop crying so now she was out
today and he he got he um
he oh he had like a little scab on his
on his knee and he was just like boo boo
and i said yeah that's your boo-boo and
he kissed it himself dude and he goes um
and kissed his [ __ ] cut on his knee
himself dude and my heart melted dude it
was so cute man love that boy man love
that boy
hugged me gave me a kiss on my [ __ ]
he just went
he's just beautiful man
kristen and i played that [ __ ] game
on twitch outlast two bro i jumped like
two three times in that game it's scary
as [ __ ] man
you have to hide under a bed and then
the [ __ ] demons are like
and look under the bed and you go whoa
in real life bro it's scary dude i want
to play resident evil because i think
that that's scary too
but that outlast 2 video game oh it's
annoying though you don't get to attack
people man all these video games are
making it too like real life i want to
attack [ __ ] give me a machete
and then [ __ ] pistol
you're walking around with a camera
after a helicopter crashed
don't you at least have [ __ ] what do
you call it uh flares
you you [ __ ] crash and you just got
this camera and you gotta document [ __ ]
bro i don't even document [ __ ] in real
life except my son
these video games man and then they're
like play uh until dawn and it's like
that game all you do is walk around and
ask people questions
the video game [ __ ] a long time ago
bobby lee tried to get me to get i got
it and i played it and i started the
video game and you start
being
born
you start by seriously you start by
coming out of your mom's wuss
hey
i want to do video games when the guy's
already all up to speed
i don't need dude it's a game about it's
an open world game where you're like
shooting guns and killing aliens and you
start
coming out of your mom's dugout
dude
i don't need to be born in the video
game unless the video game is about
babies
or your mom's hat [ __ ] wound
so gross but we're real
i would get rid of just goes like this
[Laughter]
dude you know what i'm talking about
don't make a video game where the
beginning of it is you're opening your
eyes for your first time
and your mom's fried butterflies behind
you
just give me the gun let's go
give me the gun where are the power
packs
never needs to be a baby involved okay
the video game started with push one
last push here he is and then you hear
yourself going
give me the [ __ ] lightsaber dude i'm
ready to go i cuz here i am adult me
like
already
did this stuff in real life
we got past the boring [ __ ] bro there
was a [ __ ] and you had to grow up
with the kid i mean it all takes like 20
minutes but it's like dude i don't want
to wait [ __ ] all these cut scenes
something smells weird here what is it
oh my god
then lift question mark box
i guess i gotta lift it
ah sure enough it's a dead fish i might
have to keep it for later keep
circle okay
keep you already have too many things in
your utility pack well [ __ ] get rid of
one x
okay x what would you like to get rid of
i don't know here are your items
ah for [ __ ] dude give me the gun
video games is getting more boring in
real life dude there's gonna be you know
i guarantee you first of all there's
goat simulator or some [ __ ] ah people
like play that it's actually fun keep it
no keep it keep it in the shelf no keep
it
i swear to god there's gonna be a game
called like [ __ ] fathering
and it's just gonna be like clean up
this mess x ask wife to do it box
or you know what you can do to make
everyone happy just make it so the video
game
is banging
but you can do whatever you want in the
world and don't have to do the missions
like grand theft auto you can go
[ __ ] hookers pay them kill them take the
money or you can do the missions where
you gotta rob [ __ ] and [ __ ] shoot
people and whatever or you know what you
can do in gta
chill you could just drive around that's
boring as [ __ ] but for all the boring
ass [ __ ] that want to do them
boring ass cut scenes just do that
just do that just drive around look at
the sunset
make friends with the homie you could
just walk up to someone be like what's
up
dude the [ __ ] thing that i sent you
guys
the other day the the [ __ ] can you
send me it what is it that
let me find it this [ __ ] made me laugh
bro
i'm trying to look for it
and my brother loves [ __ ] like this
hey [ __ ] you or whatever what was he'll
let me find it
god damn it
here it is i want to apologize on
youtube it's called i got it
what's up what's up you're getting on my
[ __ ] nerves all right
hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you are dead meat
i want to apologize
dude video games aren't caught up to
real life you know they try to make them
like real life by having you be born but
then it's like dude the [ __ ] talking is
unreal hey [ __ ] you [ __ ] click
click pick a gun out i want to apologize
[Laughter]
this has 16 million views dude unreal
what is this game i don't even know
gta it's gta right
i want to play it dude guy goes in gets
like people are like oh video games are
getting so real and then just imagine if
this happened in real life
what's up what's up you're getting on my
[ __ ] nerves all right
hey [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you are dead meat
i want to apologize
[Laughter]
you are dead meat you are dead meat
i want to apologize
dude it's so good you're getting on my
[ __ ] nerves
you are dead meat
i want to apologize
just got possessed you are dead meat
oh there's more there's more dude
hey dude
hello
yo
what'd it do
man you suck
you [ __ ] idiot
would you [ __ ] off
you are dead meat i want to apologize
so
quick dude
ah so quick
you are dead meat i want to apologize
[Laughter]
dude that is absolutely great dude
oh let's watch that again holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] that one's even better than the one
i saw jesus christ
hey dude
hello
yo
what'd it do
man you suck
you [ __ ] idiot
would you [ __ ] off you are dead meat
i want to apologize
[Laughter]
as if someone put you'd just be that
chill about i want to apologize like
dude you are
you are dead meat i want to apologize
look man
i really i'm out of line here i want to
apologize
while a gun's on you just not not
[ __ ] your brains out
oh [ __ ] these are great dude
oh [ __ ] i didn't know there were more
than one let's look and see if there's
more
oh man
i guess those are the only two but hold
on hold on what's this one get dick
what's a gta random npc conversations
this these are make me laugh dude
hey what up my [ __ ]
hey
what'd it do
[ __ ]
hey ass face
weirdest beat the [ __ ] out of lesser men
than you weirdest conversation ever so
far
you screwed with the wrong rental car
oh he hit him
[Music]
not listening to each other
wow that's real madness right there
all right fair enough
yo what's up
wow you know
so where you from home boy hey what's up
what's happening
ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] this is a messed up
honestly lame ass [ __ ] i don't care i
don't really give a [ __ ]
punk
i swear to god this is like a david
lynch movie
it's so weird
i don't really give a [ __ ] for no reason
with a but has a motorcycle helmet on i
want to apologize oh there's more i want
to apologize hold on
i'm going to rip you apart
i want to apologize i was stuck in
traffic dude it happened so hello
yo
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you are dead meat
i want to apologize
you're getting on my [ __ ] door one's
the one that we just saw
oh man
dude this is one fire just sent me this
i guess this is now two days before this
other
uh
getting arrested challenge
pov i turn myself in
fake situation it says by tommy talk
wow
this is another one let's watch this one
hands on your
back babe
oh he just does it again it's the same
guy
just uh sultry while he's getting
arrested always has a different necklace
on too it was a hanky and now it's a
[ __ ] pearl necklace
and to do the back of his [ __ ] thing
is always so far back the back of his
shirt is always so far back because it's
falling off needs to show his back
muscles ah
god what if that's really how you got
arrested the cop will be like what the
[ __ ] are you doing uh you can go
um
if i ever get arrested i'm gonna play
that
part the diamond song and just be when
the cops all on me just
just acting over it
[Music]
look to whoever's near me babe i love
you
cops like what the [ __ ] just go dude was
gonna arrest you for first degree murder
but this is skeeving me out
um all right that's cool we're done dude
love you guys uh you guys are a
fantastic audience and thank you so much
for listening uh we got
that
merch out we've got a bunch of different
merch we've got new merch coming right
uh one fire
no we don't no we do we not not this
time but next week
no i'm saying we get next maybe next
week look looking for some stuff but nah
um maybe not you know um
yeah we got merch here we got the life
rips we got the [ __ ] uh be more
memorable and remember to [ __ ] make
friends in those comments and everything
like that uh like and subscribe do it it
really helps our [ __ ] if you listen if
you stuck with us all the way here
throughout this episode you know what i
mean dude then maybe just like and
subscribe would help us out uh you stuck
with us this far so
uh like and subscribe on the video and
uh thanks so much for listening you guys
are great man um have a good rest of
your day or night hey guys that's the
end of the episode for youtube if you
want the raw uncut and extended version
go over on to our patreon at
crystallia.com patreon and you can uh
sign up and not only get the rest of
this episode but get the rest of every
episode that has been and then also
uh a free episode a month and you can
get all those backlogged too they you
have access to it immediately and
there's also behind the scenes there's
another [ __ ] segment we do called
review mode and you get all that as well
um
and uh and that's that's that you guys
are great thanks thanks either way
[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations
[Music]
thank you
okay here we go